hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
today we're gonna dive once again into
the waters of psychology our guest is
Olga Hassan who's written a new book
called weird the power of being an
outsider in an insider world in other
words we're talking about what it means
to be weird and we're not defining the
word weird to mean some weird thing what
we really mean in everyday life when we
just say someone is weird you know that
person's normal this one over here is a
little bit weird so what do we mean by
that what are the conditions under which
we would classify someone as weird why
do we do that right there's a sociology
problem not just a psychology question
here why do societies choose to label
certain people as weird and other people
to be normal the word normal reflects on
the fact that we're obeying norms every
society comes up with it invents rules
that you're supposed to follow and if
you don't follow those rules or not just
rules but expectations then you are
labeled weird now there's questions for
the person who is being weird also right
like there are different ways to be
weird sometimes has nothing to do with
things you can control like you're a
foreigner in a strange country sometimes
it might be your personality or your
choice of hobbies or work or whatever
there's very clear ways backed up by
psychological studies that show you how
society kind of punishes you for being
weird how it ostracize 'iz you tries to
slow you down
but as Olga argues there's also benefits
to being weird there's a certain kind of
creativity a kind of new perspective on
the world that you can get from standing
a little bit outside the norms so this
is very fun and insightful conversation
that probably everyone can relate to
because it's not that people are weird
if the different parts of every
individual person may have some
weirdness attached to them remember we
have a patreon that you can support
mindscape with patreon.com slash
Sean M Carroll and remember also I'm
doing a video series called the biggest
ideas in the universe we tackle a lot of
just very informally ideas from physics
and math and philosophy and so forth
that help us understand the
universe that we are in it's a real
video right it's not just the
talkie-talkie stuff we do here on
mindscape which is audio only you can
actually see me writing on a little pad
and you can see the little diagrams that
I draw and you can think boy that guy is
not very good at drawing diagrams but
the ideas are kind of interesting so
with that let's go
[Music]
olga hasan welcome to mindscape podcast
absolutely thanks so much for having me
on so you've written a book about
weirdness being weird what it means what
you can do about it and as someone who's
written books myself I know that this is
just asking for trouble because unlike
the Higgs boson or quantum gravity
weirdness is something where everyone in
the world is going to have a
pre-existing opinion right so what what
what induced you to take on this crazy
task yeah I mean yeah so I agree that
like it could be everything and nothing
but so what what kind of prompted this
is that I had a kind of an unusual
upbringing I grew up as a an immigrant a
Russian immigrant in West Texas and
though like I'm not I'm not currently
quote-unquote weird I live in DC and
there's foreigners and immigrants here I
really that experience kind of stayed
with me and I I became obsessed with
this idea of difference and what it
means to be different and I yeah I just
sort of really wanted to dig into like
the science behind conformity
nonconformity why we dislike outsiders
and what it's like to be just completely
different from everyone else around you
and how that affects your psyche so
that's I started reaching out to people
who kind of personified that feeling
yeah I mean obviously there's sort of
many different dimensions along which
one could qualify as weird probably
everyone thinks that they're a little
bit weird you know compared to other
people so do you have a special angle on
what you mean by weird how do you define
it yeah totally um so the way that I
defined weird for the purposes of this
book is someone who is different from
everyone else around them in whatever
context they're in so for the most part
this was looking for people reaching out
to people who were they like a male and
an overwhelmingly female profession or a
female and in a row
we male profession or like a liberal and
extremely conservative environment or
vice versa and basically reaching out to
them and and being like hey what's it
like to be you you know and yeah so it's
it's it's all it's not necessarily
people who like walking down the street
you'd be like that person they're weird
it's if people who are by the definition
of what they're doing or where they're
living are different from other people I
mean how subjective is it if one person
is weird because you know they're the
only male in a woman dominated job for
example if the same person were in a
male job then suddenly they wouldn't be
weird right so weirdness is sort of a
relationship question between a person
and their environment is that fair to
say yes totally yeah like so you're not
gonna be yeah like weirdness takes other
people like so um my favorite example of
this is so being Alda in West Texas made
me super weird my name in particular but
Olga is actually a really really common
Russian name so I went to Russia
randomly a few years ago and I was
sitting on a train and just randomly
sitting next to me on this train was
another woman with my same exact first
and middle name and Russia is your first
and middle name so because it's just
like SuperDuper common like I have like
a very common Russian name and and edito
just like so disorienting because I um I
had always been used to like explaining
my name and where I'm from and what I'm
doing here and all that stuff and it was
just very like oh yeah I'm just another
Olga like I am so yeah so that's that's
what I mean by weird is like obviously
being in Olga in Russia was not was not
weird but it's not only a mismatch
between yourself and what the rest of
the world expects is also you know
different things we can emphasize like
your name is kind of important your
gender and your political or religious
views in different contexts whereas
maybe I don't know hair color or height
or
less completely dramatic unless you're
super weird and hair color or height so
I mean it comes into not just how we're
different but what the rest of the world
cares about right yeah totally yeah it's
it's totally up to how other people
perceive you and it's funny that you
mentioned height so yeah hair color like
you could dye your hair but if you think
about height so one of the first people
that is introduced in the book is a guy
who is a short stature he's he's like
what he has dwarfism
as soon as as soon as I said that I
realized that was a bad example because
that was one of the things you talk
about a lot in the book actually sorry
no no it's okay but like yeah but but so
and and you would think like oh that's
not a big deal whatever we have like you
know actors with dwarfism Peter Dinklage
and so forth but he actually like had a
really really rough time breaking into
medicine because of that like there was
a time when you just could not become a
doctor if you weren't tall so I mean
that just gives you a sense of like yeah
this stuff definitely don't matters well
and the world you know we take the world
for granted in various ways the world of
human interaction and and employment and
so forth but the world is made for non
weird people you know like if you're if
you're a doctor that is too short to
reach the operating table there's
nothing about the height of the
operating table that is set by the laws
of nature but it makes your life hard
yeah totally well and it's that story in
particular was so strange to me because
like the stuff that was told to this guy
Michael Ain it was like oh people want
it was all about it wasn't even oh so he
stands on a step stool to reach the
operating table it's not like in an
orican incredible accommodation that he
needs like he just stands on a on a
stool but the thing that people would
always like his the people rejecting him
from medical school we're always telling
him was like people want doctors in long
white coats they want like authoritative
looking doctors who they can trust and
like a short man is just not
authoritative and it's like so
incredible that it's not even like that
they were worried that he couldn't you
know hold a scalpel or whatever
were just worried that doctors or that
patients wouldn't take him seriously
because he wasn't like what what like
you imagine a doctor in your mind to be
like yeah and III always in these
interviews like try to play the devil's
advocate a little bit even when I'm on
the other person's side so I don't agree
with this at all but isn't there a
argument to be made for that perspective
I mean part of the doctors job is to be
a reassuring authority figure like is
being tall and and dignified looking
arguably part of the job is is your
weirdness truly a hindrance there yeah
so that's definitely like I mean you see
that argument a lot in workplaces right
like whenever we go on a job interview
what are people looking for is a
cultural fit and that basically means
someone who talks the way everyone who
already works at the company talks and
acts the way everyone who already works
at the company acts and it often
excludes people who are either neuro
atypical or who are just atypical or who
don't already have that like inside
speak kind of you know hook up that you
know that the company is looking for so
yeah of course like like this is this is
like the big problem of the book is that
like is that is that we we like people
to be normal we like normal like humans
are a normal creature we form tribes we
like other people who look like us act
like us we we like the rule-followers
and when things don't follow the rules
it's unnerving and just concerning to us
and so I'm writing about what it's like
for those people who break the rules and
why we should maybe rethink the fact
that we like everything to be normal but
it's it's also true that things are
complicated right I mean that's that's
another lesson of your book is that the
whole thing is very complicated and you
know when we when we look at stories in
novels or movies or whatever it's the
weird little underdog that we're rooting
for right it's not the the perfect fit
in person that we're rooting for I think
that
we all probably like to think that we
are pro weird but maybe we exaggerate
the extent to which that's operationally
actually the case yeah I think you're
right I mean I think that you're at
you're totally right I think most people
would say like of course I'm open to
whatever I don't need a normalcy in my
life but then if you think about your
real like your revealed preferences are
for you'll see right like I don't know
it like I I think you're you're correct
that we all like to think that we root
for the underdog but you know that we
don't actually and I think a big part of
those underdog stories is the way that
the story is told is that it puts the
underdog at the center it makes them the
protagonist and tries yeah established a
bunch of commonalities between the
underdog and the viewer but if you look
at something like you know Anna Karenina
like she was an underdog who killed
herself so like like it's not every
underdog story there's a peony that is
true then he pause for a second to talk
about the peloton digital app you're
probably familiar with peloton in terms
of the bicycle that you can own at home
and get workouts on but even without any
equipment you can get a good workout
just using peloton's app you can go for
an outdoor run take a body weight
strength class or just get a breather by
meditating in front of the TV with your
family it's an incredibly convenient set
of classes that give you a workout at
home with any equipment or none at all
in a wide range of disciplines with the
peloton digital app you can access all
of peloton's content a full library
including strength meditation running
and more and you can access from many
devices your phone your tablet your
smart TV or your computer whatever is
easiest for you and now you get a 30-day
free trial which gives you the ample
opportunity to explore everything
peloton has to offer to start a new way
of working out so to learn more and
start your free peloton trial go to one
peloton comm slash app that's o-n-e PE l
OT o n dot-com
slash app download the peloton app and
start moving today
what knee the things you do in the in
the book is you do go into the details
of you know some of the psychology
studies that have been done about these
issues and so forth and one of the
things that hit home very powerfully is
how much the idea of weirdness is set by
social norms so it's not just that it's
the weird person in the outside world
but the outside world is a community of
people working together to invent these
ideas of what counts as normal and what
counts as weird maybe you want to say
something about that or we can skip
right to the example of clothes and
bathing suits and nudity and so forth oh
yeah yeah yeah okay so I can I can talk
more broadly about this and then I can I
can end on bathing suits yeah so so yeah
so kind of what we think of as normal is
determined by this concept in sociology
called
tightness and looseness and basically if
you think about like you know I don't
know how many people have seen that new
Netflix show unorthodox about the
Hasidic Jews that's like a very tight
culture it has a ton of rules there's
rules for how you dress there's rules
for how you behave there's rules for how
you get married there's rules for how
you dance at the wedding like everything
is very tightly determined by rules and
those societies have established those
rules because they're very worried about
extinction they're like very concerned
about perpetuating their society
everyone has to work together in this
very tight way in order to keep it going
now on the opposite end you have Burning
Man right you have a totally loose
society it has no rules everyone bring
whatever art projects you want you can
do drugs you can be naked you can like
whatever roll around on a four-wheeler
like it's it's you know completely
anything-goes these are very loose
societies that don't like I mean usually
these societies you don't see them as
obsessed with like perpetuating
themselves so like Burning Man is is
literally like time delimited like at a
certain point they just go home yeah but
also like if you look at like a real
example the Unitarian Universalists are
example this they have their adherence
rate is basically stagnant they have
they they've not really grown at all in
in over the course of like for more than
a century and part of that is that there
is it's not a very rural based religion
my boyfriend's a Unitarian Universalist
and you you don't really have to do
anything in that church you don't have
to like pray to God there's no like set
things that you really do and so people
just like don't do it and it's kind of
like petered out so the part of the book
where I write about bathing suits is
just like an illustration of like how a
bizarre the norms of society can be
where like you know if you go to the
pool or the like the pool of my
apartment building is like two feet from
the like street where like people are
wearing clothes that cover their butts
and like but like everyone at my pool of
my apartment that is two feet away is
like showing off their ass and like and
like their cleavage and like you know
it's just like completely letting it all
hang out because we've decided that
that's like appropriate near water
who's there near one yeah like I don't
know so I just thought it was like a
very interesting example of like we have
a ton of rules in our society that we
follow even if we don't realize it and
you mentioned that you know bikinis
typically don't cover any more than
underwear does but we'd be very
embarrassed to be seen in our underwear
and yet the bikini we actually
intentionally go out there right yeah
that was maybe I don't know I maybe like
got a little too high on my own supply
in that section because I was like I'm
like so fascinated by the norms of
slimming but like I yeah I mean like if
you if you think about like anything to
do with bathing or nudity or anything
like that that is like a very that the
whole space is just filled with with
norms no I mean I think it's actually a
great example because not only is it
filled with norms but it's the most
arbitrary right I mean what can wear any
slight deviation from the uniform of
whatever place you're in really really
gets noticed and and and I'm sure all
sorts of ways gets enforced
yeah totally well in like another good
example of this is like so yeah so most
bathing suits you know for women or at
least like for most of my childhood and
teenage years were two pieces like that
was like the most common you were like a
little like you know bikini bottom and a
little top but for a while I went to
evangelical youth group at a church and
they were gonna take us to a water park
but their rule was that you had to wear
a one-piece so that it would cover your
belly button yeah and like I don't know
it's just it was like such an
interesting example of like okay we're
okay with all of this like you can show
all of this skin but like the belly
button like please for God's sake cover
it like like you know I mean it's like I
I sort of get where they're coming from
but it's also I don't know to me like
that was such an interesting reminder of
like how many how we try to like kind of
create this you know create these rules
on the fly and they're sometimes really
strange
the female belt belly button it leads to
me the male belly button apparently has
no sexual this was also I don't know if
you know but the TV show I Dream of
Jeannie had a rule that they were never
allowed to show Barbara Eden's navel
that was that was a no-no elaborate
costume you went to do that but the rest
of her outfit is kind of sexy right like
yeah you know like like I don't think
the navel would have I actually didn't
know that but I I don't feel like the
navel would have been memorable no the
whole point was though she was supposed
to be kind of sexy and and but that was
that was judged to be too far but I mean
we should mention a little bit more
about the tight and loose distinction
because I actually had Michelle Gelfand
on as a previous guest on the podcast so
the most devoted listeners know all
about tight and loose societies and it's
it's not that one is good and one is bad
right this is part of Michelle's point
it's not that you should be tight or you
should be lose there's benefits and
disadvantages to either and in either
there's just different standards about
the extent to which you better be
following these norms yeah totally and
I'm so glad you brought that up yes
I should say tightness and looseness is
totally Michels things like she wrote a
whole book about that and if you're
interested in that you should check it
out and I like just borrowed her brain
for this part of the book but yeah like
so so when it comes to tightness and
looseness like it you know there are
advantages to living in a tight culture
like how nice to know exactly what
you're supposed to do every day and to
never have to question whether you're on
the right track or whether you're you
know doing the right thing like if
you're you know going back to the
Hasidic example if you're a Hasidic
Jewish woman of my age I would probably
be a stay-at-home mom I would have like
you know six or seven kids I would kind
of do the same thing every day I would
cook for my husband I would like follow
all these certain procedures and like
frankly some days when I wake up and I'm
like I don't know if I should email my
agent or like a story or like you know
do a bunch of interview like you know I
have a lot of like existential viii
because my life is very freeform like I
don't have any expectations on me
basically and you know like it has cost
some benefits I wouldn't want to be a
Hasidic Jewish woman but you know I also
acknowledge that like part you know that
the the there's a downside to living a
life where there's literally no rulebook
or template for you to follow well I
think that's exactly right and know I'm
probably tending towards loose myself
and my preference for where I would want
to live but I really do want to stand up
for the positive access of a tight
society like look we have you know
modern society humanity has invented a
whole lot of problems that didn't use to
exist about anxiety about the world and
how to find a job and things like that
and a lot of it is associated with the
looseness of our society and the idea of
being in a tight group of people whether
it's small or large we're you know
exactly what the rules are can make your
life a lot easier in a lot of ways yeah
I mean I think that's such a good point
I you know I I do think that a lot of
the angst that I hear and I used to like
I don't know I
I just I occasionally mentor like
younger journalists coming up in the
world and like I just hear this like
refrain of like I don't know what to do
like I don't know how to get started I
don't know what I should be focusing on
and it's not like they don't know they
literally want me to tell them it's
almost like they do want me to tell them
what to do like it's like you know there
is so many ways to like make a good life
for yourself now these days and like
that's awesome
like who wouldn't you know want that
like you know there are so many tabs
available but it's almost like this
paralysis of choice of like well which
one should I do
which one will make me happiest which
one is the best and I think that can be
really disorienting I remember the first
time I shopped for a condo and I had a
wonderful wonderful real estate agent
who showed me all these places and you
know he was very good at picking out the
good aspects of a certain place and
noticing the potential pitfalls and then
I would say well what do you think
should I get it and he's like yet no I'm
not gonna give you any guidance about
that and it was so frustrating I wanted
to be told because I had never done this
before it's a huge choice I know yeah
yeah we're starting to like let's think
about house buying and like that's gonna
be a whole other well and you also
before I forget I do want to have one
silly sounding question you know you
mentioned Burning Man as a loose society
paradigmatically loose cuz you know you
can be naked and do drugs into art but
isn't everyone at Burning Man naked and
doing drugs and doing art like if I
walked around Burning Man in a
three-piece suit wouldn't people look at
me like I was weird right like if you
really want to do a crazy art project
and Burning Man do you just like wear a
t-shirt and jeans yeah yeah I mean um oh
that reminds me of like do you remember
normcore that like yeah so it was like
I'd like to think that I was before that
even became popular that I was really
perfecting that I think that's so
awesome because it's like people are
like what's the craziest thing I could
wear I know a sweatshirt and jeans and
sneakers it's like you come full circle
to like you know the crazy is normal
anyway but that's like a good example of
what your
you're saying and like a few
sociologists told me that is like you
know as as people and especially loose
cultures look for more and more original
things to do or more like weird or crazy
ideas you kind of converge on like the
same thing so you see this with like
like the Apple like revolution where
like a first Apple was all about you
know breaking free and like not being
like 1984 and being an innovator and now
it's like who doesn't have a which is
great like very great back but like you
know you're not being different by you
and you died briefly into the physiology
of this I mean you talk about how there
is a gene that helps control your
dopamine receptors d4 and it's not that
it makes you if I understood what you're
saying correctly it's not that it makes
you act one way or the other but it just
affects how much you follow whatever the
norms are whatever the society around
you is telling you to do yeah I mean I
still think that most of this like most
of what determines whether you're like a
norm breaker or not is gonna be like
based on how you're raised and like your
own personal kind of biology and your
you know childhood home and like also
where you grow up but there is sort of
this early research that suggests that
like how much we upholds is related to
the variation we have on one gene called
the dopamine d4 receptor gene and it
basically just influences how much we
endorse the values of our culture so
like a European American who carried
this gene might become more like
individualistic and sort of pull
yourself up by your own bootstraps kind
of traditionally like American norm but
like a Asian who carried a variation of
this arm might become more
interdependent which is like a more like
Asian value of more communitarian so it
doesn't necessarily make you one way or
the other it just kind of makes you
uphold what
the values are of your environment more
but that's just one obviously like one
study there's there's so many you know
it's not like if you have this gene
you're destined to be a rule follower no
no we don't want to be too reductive
about the genes that's definitely a bad
thing but but it does point to the fact
that weirdness even though the fact that
you're weird is subjective in the sense
that it is a relationship between you
and the culture around you whether or
not you become weird might have
something to do with your genetics right
yeah totally I mean um you know and
there's also like you know a some
research that people with like autism or
borderline personality disorder actually
have a hard time kind of interacting
normally with society because they have
trouble kind of reading a social
situation and like fitting themselves in
to the norms of that environment so
there are all sorts of other like mental
health conditions and you know kind of
personality traits and things like that
that can interact with this and
influence how willing to be weird you
are yeah and I mean it is a fascinating
thing that there's so I'm just being
very obvious so them you try to be a
little bit more substantive there's the
individual and where they come from
either through nature or nurture and
then there's the Society and how it
treats weirdness right like there are
reasons from evolution and from biology
why a society would want its members to
be more or less rule-following i another
podcast I did with was with Nicholas
Christakis who talked about mild
in-group bias as one of the important
socialization factors that makes a
society work yeah totally so this is
like a area of debate I should say but
yeah so there is this idea that like
that some anthropologists have that in
our ancestral past we did have this
in-group bias that we had kind of
networks of alliances and we wanted we
kind of we liked people who were more
like us than people
we're different from us and so like I
used this example of the shitty art it's
too complicated to get into here but
essentially that we sort of had this
like little clan that we stuck to and we
liked everyone to act the same way in
this clan and that's sort of how we
survived and thrived other
anthropologists are not so sure about
that so they're by studying like more
cause like modern-day hunter-gatherers
they found that our alliances are often
a little bit more loosey-goosey than
that when they're when we're kind of off
in our natural state you know that we
would like kind of travel around and
trade with people who live hundreds of
miles away you might like live with one
clan for a while and then switch over to
another clan there's like all these like
interesting reports of from the 19th
century of like Aborigines in Australia
who would find like a beached whale and
then like have a big party for all the
other Aborigines and be like come share
our whale and like have sex with us and
like oh yeah like let's have a big party
so that doesn't seem like very like you
know like stringent or you know obsessed
with like our own group or with other
people who act like us so that it's like
it's like a little bit unclear what I
will say that was that there's a general
agreement that that it kind of when
society became more xenophobic is right
around when farming developed farming
kind of settled everyone down there
weren't as many whale parties there was
more like you know plowing and tending
fields and being more you know judicious
about your resources and what was yours
and what was someone else's and you know
you kind of start had the development of
social hierarchies some people had more
some people had less the climate changed
you started to get money and religion
and things like that so it's actually
interesting that like a warfare has
increased since that all started
happening so we think of like
farming and like you know the
development of civilization is like
being a good thing but it's actually
like we didn't really fight that many
Wars until we started having property to
fight over did you ever think that this
is what you would be talking about you
know if you answer yourself ten years
ago you'd be thinking about the origin
of farming and what it meant for people
getting along with each other yeah I you
know um yeah I don't know I thought I
thought like it was important in this
book to like go back and look at sort of
the origins of why we dislike weirdos
since that was sort of one of the
questions that I was trying to answer
yeah I wanted to like explore that and
it's a pretty traumatic idea that you're
exploring here that because we tend to
think that the way that we act in the
world and sort of socially get along
right now is more or less a law of
nature right it couldn't have been any
other way but you're suggesting that
even the simple fact that we have strong
affinities for people in our group and
tend to react negatively to people
outside our group wasn't necessarily
always like that it could have been
different and there was some transition
that was technologically driven 10,000
years ago that might have started it all
off yeah I mean that's like that's the
premise that a lot of these
anthropologists have is that essentially
when we started a kind of you know
protecting our own you know land and our
own property that is what we started
being really wary of other people coming
in and taking our stuff like if you look
back at the beached whale example we're
not gonna have you know if so many
people like flock to your beached whale
that it becomes you know impossible to
feed them all and and you have to like
drive some of them away like it's you
know there's gonna be plenty of
resources to go around and you kind of
see that today to where like in a lot of
places especially you know in part of
the book I write about the Rust Belt
towns who attracted a lot of immigrants
and I think that you see some of that
scarcity mindset in in some of those
areas where you know the people there
felt like the jobs are drying up
the kind of you know the composition of
the town is changing I'm seeing a lot
more people from spanish-speaking
countries and I made really
uncomfortable by that you know if there
was plenty to go around for everyone and
everything was like a free-flowing
you know never-ending supply of whatever
everyone wanted be it jobs or security
or you know positive good good vibes
about the future I feel like people
would be a lot more open to those
Outsiders well and it feeds back into
the tightness versus losing this
distinction right when things are going
tough when resources are scarce
societies tend to tighten up yeah
exactly yeah so that's one of the
findings from Michelle gelfand is that
when you like the the kinds of emotions
that bring forward a leader like Trump
or any of these sort of populist
kind of leaders are feelings like I'm
not gonna have enough for my own kind I
need everything to be super conformist
and super homogeneous for a while
because I am really concerned about
about the future and I'm worried about
my own kind getting enough stuff yeah
okay I mean so if we take this a bunch
of ideas here about what the idea of
weirdness is where it comes from why it
exists so the other major feature of
your book is sort of talking about what
is it good for and bad for right you
know there are both positive and
negative aspects of being weird I would
I was fascinated by this study that you
mentioned which apparently same as
though I never heard of it but the
psychology department that decided to
ostracize one of their members randomly
from week to week and even though they
knew what was happening yeah I don't
know it's that famous I just like came
across it in my research and there's a
really poignant example study of yeah so
we think about like the one thing I
often hear is like well who cares about
ostracism right like after high school
no one really cares about who gets
invited to the prom or not and who you
know is left out but it's actually still
plays a really big part in our
dull lives I think people just don't
really talk about it that much these
professors decided to each ostracize one
in their group on a given day so they
would pick a day and be like this is
your day for being ostracized and so
they were all in on it
so you would think that they wouldn't be
that upset by the ostracism like so they
would like decide not to talk to that
professor that day or just to totally
ignore them but even though they knew
that it was happening even though they
were all in on it
they actually still were really
distressed by what was happening like
they wrote that they felt like a ghost
on the floor they were like really
desperate for human interaction and that
just speaks to how troubling ostracism
can be for us even if you know we know
that it's happening and even if we are
aware that it's like just part of an
experiment so think about how
distressing it would be if you didn't
know why it was happening and it wasn't
part of an experiment I mean maybe this
is worth digging to a little bit more I
think probably that psychology study is
an especially vivid example but probably
most people are on board with the idea
that being ostracized makes you feel bad
how close is the connection with being
weird and being ostracized right there's
sort of different levels of weirdness I
suppose yeah totally I mean so not
everyone is gonna like obviously like
some types of difference in our society
are more pronounced and more look down
upon than others so like you know you
think about like the history of like
prejudiced and like obviously that was a
lot more extreme than like what the
female NASCAR driver that I you know
followed was experiencing which is just
like some low-level sexism occasionally
you know so there's like differences in
degree so I'm not trying to say like
everyone who's different experience is
at the exact same way but you do find
that like the whole reason why people
feel ostracized or or you know look down
on or discriminated against is because
the humans are a group that really
values normalcy and consistency and
rule-following and when people break
those personal rules it's really
troubling and we find it really
distressing and we tend to kind of push
away those people who violate our rules
I mean there is sort of there are layers
I guess of weirdness I was trying to
think in in my mind you know being a
transgender person is is is one kind of
way you could be weird which would lead
to certain reactions from other people
being you know really into role playing
games or something like that it's a
different way of being weird or just
being super introverted is being weird
is it is there are there studies of
commonalities in the way that these
groups get ostracized and how they cope
with them or is it just you should think
of it as a case-by-case basis yeah I
mean so there's definitely studies the
studies tend to be of like particular
groups of people so I'm trying to think
in my book it was um like their studies
of like of like gay and lesbian and
bisexual people for example so like
there's a study finding that gay lesbian
and bisexual people who experienced
homophobic language get more headaches
and chronic diseases and they are in
worse overall health and their studies
of like trans people and how the lack of
access to trans to gender affirming
bathroom you know affects trans people's
mental health so they're the studies
that tend to be done or not like hey
let's take everyone who's different and
like study them yeah they kind of be on
on subgroups of people but what I'm
talking about when I talk about these
like broader emotions of like feeling
hanging or ostracism I'm talking about
clinical studies where they bring in
people regardless of who they are and
ostracize some of them and make them
feel bad and then like you know it's not
looking at like oh were you a female
like engineer before you came into the
lab you know what I mean like they they
are what they aren't necessarily trying
to find people who are different to
start with so the studies
artificially ostracize people and then
see what the effects are yeah and like
and and sometimes the effects are good
right like so one of the studies that I
talked about in the book is one where
they ostracize someone in the group and
they found that it actually led them to
be more creative and like to really
boost their creativity but again that
was like an artificial form of ostracism
like the people who ran that study
brought in the volunteers and then they
were like you four are not picked to
work with the group like you go away and
that actually caused them to be more
creative but it wasn't like they didn't
ostracize like before trans people they
just recite for random people if that
makes sense so so you can't artificially
create this situation but if you think
about it like that's the feeling that a
lot of people who are visibly different
in some way are noticeably different in
some way deal with everyday well right I
mean it brings up the question of what
are the coping strategies I mean you
have wonderful discussion in your book
about there's a coping strategy which is
to sort of find your own people right to
find people with whom you're not weird
but there's a different coping strategy
which is to sort of flaunt your
weirdness in a different way yeah so
there's like there's different ways to
approach this and like not all of them
are gonna work for every single person
so like getting support is like the most
obvious way and that's that's a way that
a lot of a lot of people dealt with it
it's like they basically got a group to
rally around them whether it was their
family or friends but some other people
would just like get really comfortable
being um like uncomfortable like so so
one woman that I interviewed ozma who's
this Muslim woman who grew up in a small
southern town she would sort of just be
really proud to be different even though
she was different from all the
evangelical Christians she grew up
around you know she had this motto that
was like everywhere I am is a good time
which like you know so if she wasn't
drinking or if she wasn't you know
participating in like Christmas parades
or whatever else like she was still
confident in how different she was which
I thought was kind of cool it definitely
takes a lot of gusto
to be beat that way hey well yeah I was
gonna say just like it's easy to
understand that groups tend to look
warily among outsider at outsiders I
think that our first reaction is that
it's hard being thought of as weird all
the time right at being different it's
at the very least it sounds exhausting
kind of psychically yeah and that's
really like I did a run it
I am a yesterday and that's really what
like came through is that like like a
lot of folks actually like I did not so
the book is not out yet so the people
have not read it but the like you know a
lot of people a lot of trans people did
like write in and say like I feel
different at work like I'm worried about
my career how my career will be affected
by being trans you know like do you'll
be advice for trans people so I I do
think that like even though we've grown
more accepting as a society thankfully
like a lot of folks still have to deal
with the the distress of like how will
my difference my visible difference
affect me how will people see me
differently once they realize like that
I'm not exactly like them
yeah I presume that there's different
personality types that feel better with
this automatically right that you know
the example you mentioned of the woman
who enjoys being weird in different
situations probably again we all feel
that way a little bit we don't want to
be exactly cookie cutter like everybody
else but it is just a path of lesser
resistance to fit in with a wider group
right exactly yeah I mean I think like
there was like one thing I mentioned in
my book is like there's like this
optimal level of weirdness right so like
it's the most people like to be not you
know a hundred percent with the in-crowd
but also not like so different that it's
it's like bizarre so like if you think
about indie music it's like a really
good example of this like indie music is
like not that indie it's like I think
like the most popular genre of music but
people really like it
because it like feels indie right or
like it feels like you're not part of
the mainstream rock which is like
completely gone away and you're not part
of like experimental electronica that is
like totally non melodic you know in the
same with like I think the largest group
of voters is our independence which is
like another good example of this we're
like people are like I'm not part of
this group or that group I'm part of
this other group that is itself a group
like so most of us like to be somewhere
in the middle there between totally
weird and totally in with a group I mean
I guess that's true I was thinking about
how exhausting and tiring it might must
be to not fit in but at the same time
people really do like to feel that
they're not just following the group I
did a podcast with Ezra Klein on
political polarization and he brings up
the interesting fact that like you say a
huge number of Americans on a survey
will say they are independents they do
not belong to any political party but
when you ask how they actually vote they
are not swing voters there's only a tiny
fraction of these people that do not
reliably vote either Republican or
Democrat they just be like being members
of that independent group Oh totally
yeah that's like so intoxicating right
to feel like we're special snowflakes
and like we're different in some way
even though we all kind of end up doing
the same thing so what do you think are
there is there advice to be given about
what are good coping strategies if you
find yourself in a slightly weird group
should you move to a place where there
are more people like you or does the
ability of online communities help
people find like-minded folks to hang
around with and assure themselves are
they're not completely crazy yeah so I
do talk about some people who moved from
California to McKinney so that they
could be around like-minded
conservatives McKinney Texas sorry um
and I thought that was a really
interesting and extreme example of like
if you really get um you know sick of
being an oddball you can always just
like go join your your tribe where they
are but for the most part I mean one
strategy that I really liked that I
thought was was kind of a low stakes
kind of way to try this out it's called
idiosyncrasy credits and it's this idea
that like you can introduce weird ideas
and like strange kind of thoughts and
like concepts you just have to kind of
establish your normal safer you have to
kind of prove that you can fit in first
so the way to do this is like let's say
you start at a new job and you really
want to introduce like a crazy idea for
a an event right and you the firm is
like really buttoned up and you don't
think that they'll buy it so one way to
do it is just to like kind of go to your
first I don't know 10 20 meetings and be
like totally on board with everything
totally a yes man like conform as best
you can with like the low stakes stuff
and then for your big kind of ask the
one that really matters that's where you
can like break out your nonconformity
and be super you know bring out your
weird idea and kind of make your big
unusual ask and people will already feel
like well he's so part of the group he's
so like you know in line with what we
already want and like he's one of us so
why shouldn't we consider this idea
because it's being you know put forward
by someone who we consider one of us and
like a great cultural fit as they say in
the workplace so so like that's one way
if you really have like just one big
thing that you want to get across is
just to like kind of play the part a
little bit beforehand yeah I really like
this actually because as much as words
like conformity and the establishment
and so forth have a negative connotation
norms do serve a purpose right there are
reasons why societies and social groups
act in certain ways conventionally and
not in others and weirdness and
nonconformity is also important but this
sort of mixed strategy as a poker player
would call it of being a you know
showing that you you know what the rules
are and and understand them and respect
them but also occasionally want to break
them sounds like a healthy way of going
through this
right and I think this actually reminds
me of something my friend Derrick
Thompson wrote a wrote a book as well
and one of his like big findings was
like people like things that are sort of
the same as everything else except
slightly different so it's like a
similar principle here we're like you
want to be hitting like 90 percent of
like what everyone else is doing but you
want that 10% to be like your special
Flair situation so that might be a good
way to think about it especially in
places that really where it really
matters like work yeah I'm sure that
there's a physics way of thinking about
this in terms of power laws and
occasional deviations from expectations
but we won't try to do that right now
good so there's yeah so that there's the
there's the job of the weird people for
their own good to survive and flourish
and and and get through life I guess we
didn't go into the online possibilities
like are you a fan of not just moving
from one place to another but finding
your like-minded you know spiritual
brethren online yeah I mean I really
don't do that I don't spend a lot of
time online with with other people I
don't know why that is I just really
prefer like if I'm gonna hang out with
people I prefer to do it in person but I
think a lot of people really do get a
lot of solace from that and really enjoy
online communities and like online you
know gaming and like things like that i
I just personally can't speak to that
because I don't do it but but I
obviously like that's a huge community
at that point though I would question
like like whether you really feel
different because you you obviously like
like are then part of a big community
and like some people that community is
bigger for them than like what's going
on in their real life so I would say
like that that's great that's a great
way of community building but I would
say that person probably is not
struggling with some of the situations
that I'm bringing up in my book yeah
okay I mean and we also so then the
flipside of this is this is the
individual who's a
but weird learning coping strategies
either finding like-minded Souls or
deploying their weirdness at strategic
moments the other side is the community
making use of weirdness right like you
already mentioned creativity as
something that might come out of being a
little bit weird maybe say more about
how those two things related yeah I mean
there's like a pretty vast body of
scientific research showing that as you
add dissenting voices to a group they
actually the group makes better
decisions that there was like a famous
Solomon Asch study or variations on the
Solomon Asch study that that showed this
that essentially like the it in order to
make a good decision you need people who
don't all agree perfectly because if
you're all agreeing perfectly you're
you're too pointed in the direction that
where you have like this inescapable
momentum and that's how you get things
like you know Enron or whatever the
other famous examples of groupthink are
where you have people who are just like
getting carried away with drinking their
own kool-aid but if you you know you
need those dissenting voices to kind of
like you need the cooling saucer the
weirdo there to like to - you know get
everyone to consider other possibilities
because you know otherwise it's just
like way to do group thinking and so so
yeah so like Society I mean this is like
a huge call for you know including
diverse voices and diverse viewpoints
and anything where there's like a broad
consensus being formed definitely the
media but also you know other situated
like policymaking or you know business
decision making it's hugely important to
have diverse perspectives in that
situation just because you want people
to kind of be that that kind of crucible
of friction with you and that you can
make the best decision possible
well it's certainly applicable to
academia I know where you
in an area like theoretical physics
sometimes there's not a lot of data that
you can rely on and it's just a bunch of
people and their ideas and everyone
probably would agree that it's good to
have some outside the box ideas in the
mix but then when you're a an actual
department trying to hire somebody are
you gonna hire the one outside the box
person who is maybe going to
revolutionize everything but probably
not going to do anything at all or you
get a higher person who's working in the
mainstream and likely to give some solid
contributions and the answer is almost
always you're gonna go for the person
likely to give some solid contributions
it's just too much of a risk to get out
there and we end up being a little bit
stodgy er than we should be because of
that yeah I think yeah I've heard that
I'm not an academic but I've heard that
complaint about academia before but you
also have like you know to speak from my
own real house in the media you know a
lot of these big like when people do say
that the media is too alarmist or that
there's some big press thing that the
press blows out of proportion a lot of
that happens because people are kind of
taking a cue from each other and no
one's taking a second to be like wait a
minute how much do we really know here
and are there other possibilities we
could be thinking about because people
don't want to be considered weird right
yeah so like a good example of this is
crack babies the media in the 1980s did
a bunch of reporting about the future
crack babies of America and how like
they're basically gonna be mentally
challenged and they're not gonna be able
to like keep up with society and we've
like completely doomed these babies to
be like crack addled for life and I'm
not saying that crack is fine but I'm
saying that like those that didn't
actually happen like those kids like the
level of of cognitive disability was
much much lower than was predicted and
the idea that this whole generation of
especially inner-city African Americans
was somehow doomed to be like vegetables
was totally wrong and I think that
that's because
like it bounced from like you know the
New York Times Time magazine - you know
Newsweek - this and that and like people
just didn't take time to put the brakes
on it and that you see that happen a lot
yeah yeah and and maybe a little bit of
dissenting voices I mean it's
interesting because it appears in many
different contexts I mean you're talking
about the psychology and the sociology
of being a weird person in a group but
then there's just sort of the political
science of having dissenting voices and
you know the free-market of ideas and
stuff like that and it goes to the same
place are there benefits to being weird
besides creativity like I mean can we
can we give the sales pitch for why you
should be proud of your weirdness a
little bit yeah the other big advantage
that I really zero in on in the book is
this tendency to really know and stick
to your core principles really really
truthfully like to be really sure of
what you want in life and what you're
doing and kind of like be more confident
than most people are in in that in that
way and I know that sounds a little
vague but to give you an idea like some
of the people that I was most impressed
by were the people who were online
dating back when that was considered
really strange and like a good way to
get activated and like you know like the
way they talked about it Lorde they were
like you know I didn't matter what
people said I just love this person I
thought what we were doing was cool like
I was comfortable with it I was happy to
be you know like this kind of weirdo who
is like reading over my emails back
before there was like email really you
know um so like and obviously like and
they found they're still married those
couples like and they have this
wonderful origin story that is like so
unique and so um so cute and of course
not every everything you do is gonna be
like that but you know I just I just
thought it was it was you know a good
example of how if you really believe in
something even if everyone thinks it's
weird it often helps you find your moral
compass and stick to it if you're if
you're really committed
I think that makes sense that's a really
good point as we as we wrap up here
because exactly because there's so much
social pressure on you when you are
deviating from the norm when you sort of
sit back and think okay should I be like
this anyway despite the fact that
there's social pressure on me it really
does
in principle I think it could help you
figure out what's so important what's
maybe not so important yeah exactly yeah
it helps you kind of separate the wheat
from the chaff of like you or your own
your own inner inner man and it goes
back to what you said about you know the
the idiots think IDEO sing cracy credits
that you have like if you maybe want to
be weird in a hundred different
dimensions but maybe it's worth sitting
down and thinking about what where is it
worth it like if I go along with the
flow because it's just not worth the
struggle and where the others were I'm
really gonna fight for my difference
here yeah I totally I mean this is yeah
this is why I recommend people just
dressed really boringly at the office
because you want to save your chips for
the fight with your boss about more
important stuff I'm on your side there
all right so the last thing I just
wanted to ask you know you start the
book with your own experience of
weirdness right you grew up an immigrant
in a conservative Texas town and so
forth has this study that you've done of
all these different ways of being weird
and so forth has this changed how you
think about your own variety of
weirdness which was kind of mostly
external right those things you were
born into not things you chose yeah
totally yeah I guess so I started to
rethink whether I start to rethink
whether it was really that different
from people in my hometown like that
maybe the feeling that I've had my whole
life is not was more an internal than I
liked more at least like internally
perpetuated than externally perpetuated
like I started to rethink whether people
were really whether my parents and I
were really like as harshly look down
upon and judged as I as I kind of feared
that we were yeah that's that's kind of
the main thing that I started to rethink
yeah this is like my own my own
weirdness I guess no I mean actually I
think that's a fascinating thing that I
didn't even think that to talk about we
were sort of
taking weirdness for granted as a thing
but not only is it subjective what
counts is weird but a little bit of
judgment goes into thinking whether or
not we actually are weird and maybe we
perceive ourselves as either weird or
not weird in a way very different from
what the society we're in is judging us
to be yeah totally I mean your self
perception is a you know a huge huge
part of things and as someone like I
have a lot of social anxiety which like
I think causes me to maybe overstate the
the negatives when it comes to like how
different I am from people and so I've
tried to like correct for that toward
the end of the book yeah well I think
that I think it's a good I recommend the
book absolutely to listeners out here
it's a good way of trying to tune
ourselves to be just the right amount of
weird which is a good goal but a tough
thing to achieve yeah okay Olga's on
thanks so much for being on the
mindscape podcast absolutely thinks I
might ride me on it was fun
[Music]
you
[Music]